right now it is time for our draft the
most important match-ups of week three
chris i have a question for you to
determine the first pick in the draft
former washington state cougar gardener
the ginsu minshu will start his second
career game tonight there's only one
other washington state quarterback
currently in the nfl and he's also
starting this week who is he oh well
that's an easy one uh that would be luke
falk or the new york jets
thank you thank you you get the easy
questions
way to go thank you everybody back there
that was a good one
uh this is a good day to have the first
pick
because uh i did not pop to me that
there was like a ton of interesting
match-ups in this week as maybe compared
to other ones but my first one will be
this right off the bat
and uh i i'm gonna go the ravens
defensive line versus the chiefs
offensive line okay uh or you know
whatever you want to say if you want to
say the ravens d-line vs patrick mahomes
but either way that is one of the key
match-ups to the marquee game of the
weekend for me you know ravens chiefs
mahomes lamar jackson one of the things
you watch with the kansas city chiefs
their offensive line their past
protection is phenomenal whether it's
the jacksonville jaguars or just think
about some of the plays you saw last
week with the oakland raiders man my
homes was kind of just sliding around
throwing bombs around but nobody in the
screen
and we just watched some clips of that
baltimore ravens defense trying to chase
down patrick mahomes from last year so
that is a key to the football game
because you can't blitz them a whole lot
or they're gonna burn you because
they're too talented uh on the outside
and you just got to be able to get some
pressure with your front four and
that'll be a marquee match up for me
because this chiefs o line is one of the
better ones in football when it comes to
pass protection
and i love the andy reid john harbaugh
subplot here as well because harbaugh
was an assistant in philadelphia before
he became the coach of the ravens and
he's been there since 2008 but andy reid
was the head coach in philly harbaugh a
special teams coordinator who had one
year as defensive backs coach to kind of
erase that stigma that special teams
coordinators shouldn't be head coaches
well they should be and harbaugh was
primarily a special teams guy and has
been one of the best coaches in the nfl
so i that's the obvious first pick
especially because we just were watching
on the tv side those great patrick
mahomes moments from last year's classic
ravens chiefs game at arrowhead stadium
all right for me i'm going to go with
the game we were talking about earlier
as it relates to the guessing game that
is going to be played between sean
payton and pete carroll the head coaches
two of the best in the league they each
have a super bowl trophy they're getting
together in seattle in a game that
becomes a tougher task for the saints
without drew brees but we're gonna see
how good sean payton is right we got to
see a full season of drew brees without
sean payton in 2012 now we see four five
six weeks of sean payton without drew
brees how can he draw up plays can he
crack the code on that defense with
teddy bridgewater and taysom hill which
guy will get the ball more will they
both be on the field at times will they
exploit weaknesses in the seattle
defense that's what i'm looking forward
to that should be a very good game as an
and a very important match up as these
two coaches match wits with the saints
being
undermanned but still having a couple of
potential tricks that they can they can
unleash on pete carroll and company bro
i mean you're right i think this was an
obvious uh second pick right here
because it this is this is uh the other
big game of the weekend for sure between
sean payton pete carroll and you
mentioned all of it all the things we
know the mad scientist that sean payton
can pull off with an offense and now you
know as i always say you know sometimes
these guys get even more creative when
the backups come in because they go oh i
got to find more ways to give us a
little edge or an advantage so i think
that's going to be a phenomenal thing to
watch what sean payton does the design
runs her chase some hill and pete
carroll is going to have to get his
and team ready for just about every
trick underneath the sun as far as
football is concerned so i'm with you
there good pick um my next one will go
to our sunday night football matchup uh
i think that's where i gotta go and i'm
gonna go freddy kitchens versus wade
phillips that matchup right there
will determine who can win that football
game on sunday night freddie kitchens
more patient with the run game last week
against the new york jets but this is
one theme i've seen through the first
two weeks mike when you watch cleveland
on film
uh whether it was dean peace in the
tennessee titans or greg williams of the
new york jets putting people at the line
of scrimmage confusing baker mayfield
and also trying to make it look like oh
yeah go throw the ball you got
one-on-one out here you know with o'dell
and jarvis landrieu yeah drop back throw
the ball it's a really good look to
throw it into and then they drop out and
protect the secondary right and don't
rush and that's one thing where freddie
kitchens has to stay patient with that
run game uh and continue to do that so
these defensive coordinators are not uh
disguising and trying to trick their
young quarterback quite as much but the
battle of wits right there i think will
go in a long way to determining who wins
that football game yeah you know i was
going to pick one from that same game
i'm not going to now but i think it's
more mayfield versus wade phillips yeah
sure
and you know we've seen that he does try
a little bit too hard to force balls
into spots maybe he shouldn't he
admitted he's got to learn how to check
down there was that play where he threw
an interception on monday night he had
nick chubb wide open 15 yards shorter
than where mayfield threw the ball i was
tipped it was picked off what kind of
looks will wade phillips show him and
erin donald i mean aaron donald just you
know ripped up drew brees thumb last
week not on purpose but still that adds
to the overall aura and stigma of having
this guy f up the play as you would say
each and every snap so that that that
game uh i keep going back and forth on
who i like on that i know does that but
does aaron donald personify the f up the
place that more than anybody else yes
it's unreal right he's got what what
does he have two tackles on the year
that's it so far i mean and he's the
best player in football i mean he ruins
plays like every other play it's unreal
should we just call it the aaron donald
stats so we don't have to continuously
say f up the play and and ensure we
won't accidentally say the word we
shouldn't say well i would like you to
like maybe we just named that after me
you wanted to be the chris sims i wanted
to be the chris simpson so there's the
chris sim surgery and the chris sims
stat today i think we've come away with
i'd like those to be coined please
and and really as you learned 13 years
ago enough of the chris sims stat will
lead to the chris sims surgery yes
exactly right yes exactly right
all right next one for me and this is a
weird little early season round robin
between the bears the packers and the
broncos it was bears and packers week
one bears and broncos week two broncos
packers week three and you know i
pointed this out last week you got a
young coach in matt laflore and he's
getting his baptism by going against a
couple of the older coaches in the nfl
he beat mike zimmer what's he gonna do
with vic fangio fangio coming back to
the scene of that heartbreaking week one
loss when the bears had the packers down
fangio was the defensive coordinator
back comes aaron rodgers with that knee
injury and shreds the bears defense
he doesn't have quite the same caliber
of player although that broncos defense
still has some good players and fangio
extra salty after getting screwed not
once but twice on the last drive of the
game against chicago i want to see what
vic fangio throws at aaron rodgers
toughest test yet for that offense
because fangio knows a thing or two
about going after uh getting after and
ultimately shutting down aaron rodgers
not that it worked last year in week one
right but it did happen later in the
year so i i that to me that's a a sneaky
great game on sunday because you know
the fact that broncos zero and two
you're thinking that yeah the packers
should win this one i'm not so sure i'm
gonna hand them the w no i get you there
i mean denver's defense it's still real
i mean we know that i mean it's not like
they're laying eggs out there and yes
vic fangio does you know got a good feel
for aaron rodgers and and everything now
it is left floor this year so there's a
few new wrinkles there but um yeah this
could be a defensive struggle i mean
think about the damn packers you had to
open up the season against the bears the
vikings and the broncos three of uh the
more intimidating defenses all in
football but the good thing is is they
have a defense this year and they can
win some of these ugly games and if they
got a win 1916 i think they can pull it
off
uh remember that game yeah it was a
sunday night game the year the broncos
won the super bowl and yes they held
aaron rodgers to like 78 yards throwing
or something right right yeah yeah and
uh and again not the same quality of
defense as it was that year but still a
lot of the piece is still in place and
uh it should be an interesting matchup
all right what do you got yep i think
okay my last one
not necessarily like a battle of the
titans here for like uh nfc supremacy
but i still think this is a very
important matchup and of course a big
storyline i'm gonna go with daniel jones
versus todd bowles down in tampa bay
making his first start replacing eli i
made the point and i know you've heard
me say it that you know the thing that's
interesting here is daniel jones plays
against this type of defense every day
in practice and in training camp the
defensive coordinator for the giants
james betcher he learned under a guy in
todd bowles in arizona so you know what
can todd bowles do differently or his
his plan of attack to maybe make life
hard on daniel jones and then daniel
jones just being comfortable what he
sees
i think that can go a long way and just
to the success overall of daniel jones
and of course if they want to pull off
an upset in tampa
he's going to have to feel comfortable
and have a good feel for that todd
bowles defense so that'll be something
i'm certainly going to watch for early
on to see if todd bowles does some
different things or how comfortable you
know daniel jones looks in general
it was a win in tampa too back in the
2007 playoffs that sparked eli manning's
run to suit that's right 42. back when
they were the five seed had to go on the
road they went on they did it the hard
way it's amazing that not only that they
won two super bowls but the fact that
they had to really work to get their
both seasons all right my this one now
the new england patriots have been to
four of the last five super bowls and
they would have won four of the last
five super bowls if they'd been able to
beat the eagles and it was a game where
the new england offense did nothing to
undermine the effort to win the game tom
brady had over 500 yards passing and
they scored all the points they needed
to score but it was the defense that
fell apart that defense was run by matt
patricia matt patricia takes his lions
to philadelphia to take on doug peterson
and patricia's getting his shot at
redemption good one mike against doug
doug peterson for the first time since
super bowl 52. so look i don't know that
the lions have the horses but they tied
arizona they beat the chargers the
eagles are banged up
and i think that there's a lot of
potential play there between how
patricia does or doesn't shut down you
know it was different quarterback it was
nick foles not carson wentz but still
that that chalkboard battle between matt
patricia and doug peterson the decisions
made on the fly and patricia is going to
be constantly thinking about the fact
that he'd have another super bowl ring
and the patriots would already be at
number seven if they had been able to
solve just a little bit right the eagles
offense that day in minnesota yeah that
was a butt whooping for sure i mean it
certainly was not the best day for matt
patricia as a defensive coordinator uh
and this is a good one by you i hadn't
thought about that you know aspect of
that match up so that will be cool and
you know you said it i think there's a
little danger here for philadelphia with
as banged up as a football team as they
are after that sunday night game and as
physical and crazy as it was
i do worry about them and how can i not
worry about their secondary just a
little bit against matt stafford and tj
hawkinson and marvin jones and gallaudet
and company that's a little dangerous
too so
i would not be shocked if the lions went
in there and gave the eagles a real run
for their money that's for sure
oh and another thread the eagles
defensive coordinator jim schwartz was
the head coach of the lions when matthew
stafford was the first overall pick 10
years ago so that should be that's a
sneaky good game
on sunday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports